[Music]
the greatest film of the original
trilogy one of the best sequels ever
made and the movie Star Wars fans love
the most just so happens to be the one
where George Lucas was involved the
least hmm
the Empire Strikes Back you love the
fun-filled space adventure where evil is
vanquished and everyone gets a medal yay
now watch the rebellion get crushed the
comic relief get frozen and the ultimate
evil tell the hero who's your daddy i
evil father and a sequel so dark it's
become the lazy shorthand for any time a
franchise turns even slightly to the
dark side yeah well this is actually the
Empire Strikes Back of honest trailers
so there yeah
witness a movie full of excellent
directing great acting brilliant
dialogue gorgeous music and iconic
moments that will stay with you for a
lifetime I love you I know but let's see
what the nitpick here sometimes they
pronounce Han Solo's name different ha
ha you suck perfect movie ah this is
gonna be a tough one isn't it revisit
all of your favorite characters three
years after they shot their balls into
the egg hole like Princess Leia he's
proof that Lucas either didn't have
these movies planned out as much as he
claims or he was into some pretty weird
stuff han Solo a charming smuggler who's
not afraid to make a point with his
hands and Luke Skywalker the magical
moisture farmer there's no longer a
whiny Brad now he's just dumb whether
he's crashing his x-wing into a swab
getting tricked into a hole
running out of a warm cake to freeze to
death losing a fight to slow moving
pieces of furniture or ignoring the
advice of the last living Jedi must
complete the training I can't keep the
vision out of my head they're my friends
I gotta help them well if they have a
spare in a world where sequels and
reboots Coast buy on nostalgia alone
enjoy a sequel that takes everything you
love about Star Wars and actually builds
on it adding all new worlds like Hoth
a planet made of ice Dagobah a planet
made of snakes and Bespin a planet made
of matte paintings
each one of them full of amazing all new
characters like Lando Calrissian a
gambler who won a mining company in a
card game
I think Boba Fett the biggest movie
badass with the least amount of screen
time and of course Yoda the Jedi Master
who trains Luke in the ancient art of
entering spooky caves not trying
anything there is no try and flipping
for no reason
wait a second these pointless gymnastics
remind me of someone
that's where the prequels got on the
dumb flipping around from whoa mind
blown
so strapped in for the Star Wars movie
that's so good they barely touched it in
the special editions representing the
absolute peak of the franchise when the
prequels could still be good then we go
back 20 years and we do the story of
young Darth Vader and young the young
Alec Guinness character and in the third
film which proceeds to our Wars you see
like a prequel that's right they had an
actual end date inside if Lucas makes
all nine episodes the force may be
around until 2001 and people didn't take
these make-believe characters so
freaking seriously han Solo and Princess
Leia and and the Wookiee and and c-3po
incipio starring the wookie 3cp oh Cool
Hand Luke Ray's mom or aunt or something
hand point-o worst kinder egg ever a
dota sham be know the dude from the
holiday special the hardest level in the
Rogue Squadron n64 game and run run run
jump I can be your backpack while you
run the Empire Strikes Back of Star Wars
like father like son I guess
he is the most iconic villain of all
time
now we'll show him the true power of the
dark side they say girls want a guy that
reminds them of their dad that's why
I've been using my vibrator so much you
hear that obi-wan I've got the high
ground now me you dick
tough black exterior with a soft weak
white man inside you're not a thick
you're Drake screen junkies presents the
roast of Darth Vader exclusively on
screen junkies plus watch now this sad
display is exactly why I watch Star Trek
live long and prosper nerds this will be
a day long remembered the roast of Darth
Vader is here click the box on the left
to watch the second worst roasting of
Anakin Skywalker's life from obi-wan
Kenobi Yoda and Luke Skywalker and more
you can watch for free when you register
with a Facebook account and if the force
still isn't with you click the Box on
the right to watch our special screen
junkies news coverage from Star Wars
rogue one where we interview the cast of
the film you will click the boxes and
watch now let's move along to some
comments it's not a hug I'm just
grabbing the door for you I secretly
work for OWCA the organization without a
cool acronym Punk's jump up to get beat
down I am NOT throwing away by shot I am
NOT throwing away my shot on all levels
except physical I am a depressed
starfish